We can cancel an x minus 3 in the numerator and the denominator. We can also
cancel an x minus 2. Now we're left with these factors. We want to be careful
here. We can't simplify 3 x minus 2 and 3 x plus 2. They're not identical
rational expressions. And they're not opposite polynomials, since the 3 x have
the same signs. The same is true of x minus 3 and x plus 3. The signs for the x
terms are the same. So these are not identical polynomials, and they're not
opposite polynomials. We can, however, simplify 2x and 6x. You know, x divided
by x equals 1. And 2 divided by 6 reduces to 1 third. You want to make sure you
don't forget about monomial terms. Be sure to cancel common factors for the
numbers. And common powers for the variables. After we've done that we have our
simplified rational expression, 3x minus 2 times x minus 3 and 3x plus 2 times 3
times x plus 3.